(Vanessa groans)
(both laughs)
- Wow it really didn't wanna, there we go.
Okay.
- Jeez.
- Who hides in the bakery at Christmas?
- Who?
- A mince spy.
- A what?
- A mince spy?
- I don't get it.
- You don't have mince pies here?
(festive music)
- Hey, I'm Vanessa Hudgens.
- And I'm Josh Whitehouse.
Welcome to British Quizmas.
Where there are no prizes,
just the thrill of the game.
In the UK,
while many say happy
Christmas or merry Christmas
it's not uncommon to shorten the greeting
and say merry Chrimbo.
- No, false.
(buzzer)
- No, it's true.
- What?
- The British are well known
for their colloquialisms.
And this one is actually quite popular.
So merry Chrimbo to you.
- Chrimbo?
- Yeah, Chrimbo.
Yeah.
- Chrimbo.
- You don't know it?
- No.
- Hmm.
- It's not gonna stick with me.
I'm really trying my hardest
to not look at the answers.
- Well you get out with your cheeky eyes.
(Vanessa laughs)
True or false?
The British often refer
to December the 26th
not as the day after
Christmas but as Boxing day.
- Yes, true.
Or is that Americans?
- Dun dun dun dun dun.
- I don't know, yeah?
Sure, true.
(bell dings)
- Yes, it's true.
It's the start of post Christmas sales,
similar to Black Friday in the U.S.
- Yeah.
Okay, cool.
- Instead of Christmas trees,
the British prefer Christmas shrubbery.
An assortment of decorative plants
spread throughout the house.
A tradition which dates back
to the thirteenth-century.
True or false?
(Vanessa laughs)
(Josh laughs)
Shrubberies.
- Shrubbery.
- Around the house.
- No, false.
I want a Christmas tree.
- Yeah, you're right.
(bell dings)
It's completely false.
The British most certainly
use Christmas trees.
- Yeah, okay.
- True or false?
One Brit who famously
does not love Christmas
is Ebenezer Scrooge.
A little known fact is that Scrooge
is actually based on England's
Prime Minister at the time,
Sir Robert Peel.
- True?
(buzzer)
- It's false.
(Vanessa laughs)
Scrooge is simply a creation from
the brilliant mind of Charles Dickens.
- Okay, oh yes.
Of course, Charles Chargoly.
- Every year at Christmas,
the Queen sings a
Christmas carol to everyone
in England over the radio.
Last years choice was "All I
Want for Christmas is You".
- False.
(bell dings)
- Yeah, that's right.
She does not sing a carol but
she does offer the whole country
a royal Christmas message every year.
A tradition that dates back to 1932.
- I saw her riding a horse the other day.
- Yeah.
It's great, she's such a bless.
- In England, children
typically hang their stockings
at the end of their bed instead of
over the fireplace as they do in America.
- False.
(buzzer)
- It's true.
- Oh, did you?
- Ah...
- No.
- You didn't.
- No, but it's true.
(both laughs)
I'm a special case.
It is believed in England that
all decorations and your tree
must come down within 12 days
following Christmas or you'll have
bad luck for the rest of the year.
- I'll say true.
(bell dings)
- Thank you.
Don't get your year started
off on the wrong foot.
It is true.
- Yeah.
- Do you know...
- The muffin man.
- The muffin man?
- Ah is he married to the muffin man?
- Do you know what this is?
Or these, I should say.
- I've seen them?
- No.
(buzzer)
That's always baffled me.
I thought that was a thing everywhere.
- What is it?
Is there something in it?
- It's a Christmas cracker.
- It's a popper?
- Well, basically what you do is...
You're not supposed to
put your fingers inside--
- Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
- Yeah, c'mon.
You gotta get this right, okay?
- How do you do it?
- So what you do is you each
take a side and you pull it.
- I don't like loud noises.
- And one of you will get this center bit
which has a toy inside
or maybe a joke or--
- Is it loud?
- No, it doesn't even make a slight sound.
- Okay, go!
- I was kinda hoping for a bigger bang.
And aw look, you got a fish.
- I got a fish?
Oh it's the fish that's
like sensitive to heat.
- Yeah you put it on
your hand and it dances.
Oh look at him go.
- Whoa.
(Josh laughs)
- It's moving so much.
Okay, and then you got a Christmas hat.
And there's even a joke here or something.
- What does Cinderella say when
her photos didn't arrive on time?
One day my prints will come.
(both laughs)
That's great, I like that.
- What do you get if you
cross Santa with a duck?
- What?
- Christmas quacker?
He's a quackers.
Thanks for watching us
play British Quizmas.
- And make sure you watch
The Night Before Christmas,
only on Netflix.